hello welcome to my presentation
i am nikki osbourne dialing in today
from
new zealand uh thank you for tuning up
now if
you are watching this you probably have
one of these
and a series of events choices and
decision-making processes
have got you to be sitting where you are
in this moment
but do you think you'd be able to
recognize and recall what all of those
events are
and what decisions lead you to this
point
probably not and as i'm talking to you
and you're watching the slides your
brain is engaging in a multitude of
tasks that you have no real conscious
aware of
awareness of and how you perceive the
presentation how much you're able to
engage with the material
and whether or not you stick it out to
the end might have much less to do with
how good i am at presenting the material
and much more to do with
how hungry you are whether you're
distracted by an argument you had with
your partner maybe your kids are in the
next room
uh and or perhaps you've heard me talk
before and you've already formed an
impression of me
or maybe you're critical of the need to
understand cognitive bias
maybe you're sitting there watching in
your pajamas or uh
sitting in bed anyway my point is
before i've even begun the thoughts and
stories in your subconscious
are going to be informing your conscious
perception of my words and the material
and and your ability to understand will
have a lot more to do with what's going
on
underneath and that's just a function of
being human
our brains are con constantly taking
shortcuts in order to perceive the world
around us
and this helps us to make decisions
quickly and efficiently
so grab a pen and paper if you have it
handy and i'm gonna get you warmed up
get your brain warmed up
before we get into the good stuff so
count how many x are in the following
sentence
right have you done that you've had a
read
how many of you got three four five
most people who haven't seen this before
will see four
in fact there are six
and the reason that you probably didn't
see
the ones that's ended and of
are because your brain fills in the gaps
knowing that
of the and these words don't have
meaning
um so you look for the finished files
probably
maybe scientific you saw the f in there
but all the words in between
uh essentially don't have meaning and
you're
and they're filler words and your brain
just skips over them
what does this slide say
perhaps if i gave you an extra couple of
seconds you may
read you may notice that it's i love
paris and thus
that's springtime uh but initially your
brain probably read it as i love paris
in the springtime
because attached to the words that have
meaning and filled in the rest
what about on this slide which is a or b
has the darker shade of gray
if you've seen this before you'll know
it's a trick question
as both a and b are exactly the same
shade of gray
however our brains know that shadows
cast
a dark make darkness and so our brains
automatically see
b as being lighter than a because it's
under a shadow
what about on this slide are you can you
see the black dots
on the left hand figure are they moving
around
because they're not really there what
about the other two
do they look like squiggly lines or
parallel lines
they are parallel but it's the context
around them that's making your brain see
them differently
well how about here a and b
on the left hand figure are exactly the
same size
but our brains want to see a is being
same with the middle finger those lines
are exactly the same size
the context makes our brain see one as
being smaller than the other
and the circle the orange circles are
both exactly the same
size even knowing this it's very hard
for our brains to truly believe that
even myself i've had to get out and
measure these multiple times
they are in fact exactly the same
all right so would you make a good
witness we're going to have a little bit
of a memory test here
so i'm going to read out a list of words
when i say so i want you to write down
as many as possible so don't write them
down yet just have a wee listen
bed rest
awake tired
snooze blanket
dose fake
slumber
okay write down as many as you can
remember
all right now i'm going to read them out
again and you can take as many as you
got
bed rest awake
tired snooze blanket
does sleep wake
slumber north peace
yawn drowsy dreams
so how many did you get and did you
record the word sleeves
about 70 of you would have remembered
hearing sleeves
even though i never actually said it in
the first list that i read out
the word association and image made you
think of words that were likely in the
list
rather than remembering what was
actually there
and if you didn't misremember sleeps you
likely only remember about five to seven
words
and possibly additional words related to
sleep
that i didn't read out okay so if i
haven't managed to get you on all of the
last ones we'll give one last
uh figure a go so i want you to cover
your right eye
look at the black star and move slowly
towards the screen
and and tell me what happens to the
colored star
now you can tell me what happens to the
color star obviously i'm not going to be
able to hear you
um but the color star will disappear at
some point
now this will depend obviously on how
big your screen is how far away you're
sitting
but if you're covering one eye as you
move back and forth
you'll notice that one disappears
so just like our eyes are not able to
see everything our brains are
also not able to take everything in at
once it must ignore
some information and data to find the
easiest route to information processing
and this is what we call cognitive bias
and it's a deviation in judgment whereby
inferences about people situations and
data
may be drawn in a logical fashion
contextual bias is the one we talk about
most often in forensic science so
this is a deviation and judgment caused
by exposure to information
that is either irrelevant to the
judgmental task
or inappropriate for consideration
and biases may affect the reliability
and validity of one's observations and
interpretations
and this is why it's so important to
understand it in terms of who reads
reasons decision making
i want to be really clear that we're not
talking about intentional or malicious
behavior
so it's not this idea of getting rid of
samples or only testing certain things
that you know will produce
um inclusionary results or exploratory
results we're not talking about that
we're talking about the things that go
on in your brain that you're really not
aware of
uh now cognitive bias research and
forensic science really started to take
off
around 2005 2006 with a few
uh early studies in the area of
fingerprint expertise by etl similar
and this came off the back of
the brandon mayfield case where the fbi
had misidentified
his fingerprint in a
in a madrid bombing case and
and what etl found was that when you
present
analysts with contextual information
that suggests
that the fingerprints either do match or
they don't match
in some cases the analysts will
will be biased towards going along with
that particular information
since then there have been
numerous uh contextual biased studies
across all forensic disciplines
and and i'll be talking a little bit
more about some of the challenges of
these studies later on
um but basically the overall general
design
of these is that lay people or forensic
experts are given data
to interpret so the fingerprints fire
marks blood stains epgs
alongside some form of contextual
information that can be potentially
biasing
then researchers measure the effect of
this uh information
on the decisions that participants
produce
now i don't have time to go into the
findings of all of those but what i will
do is highlight
the instances where size can be as
potential
issues
so bias is only found when there is
ambiguous
ambiguity in the evidence or the
evidences of low quality that is it may
be distorted
or have parts of it missing
it happens more often when there are
subjective masses of interpretations
when there's task irrelevant contextual
information and we will be talking a
little bit more about this later on
uh because some information of course is
relevant
and necessary to use but it's that task
irrelevant information makes sense
uh in a negatively biasing way
uh if you have a lack of training or
competency through a study that has
compared novice ex
novice analysts to experienced analysts
generally the effect is more pronounced
in novice analysts
and the lack of independent review will
checks and balances
so what are some challenges when
conducting and understanding the
findings of cognitive bias
research
these studies are not particularly easy
to design
and the many factors that it's very hard
to replicate
case work sources and conditions
uh and because we're trying to produce
ground truth samples
uh and there's often
small sample sizes so this is one of the
critiques of many of the
fire studies is that
some only have five six ten twelve
participants
as these are starting to increase and as
time's gone on we're definitely seeing
a rise and there's so many variables to
consume this
uh and for example when bloodstream had
an analysis
there are many different mechanisms that
can cause
a particular blood stain so if you
create a study that's only looking at
one particular stain
then you may be missing out on vital
information
so generally only testing one part of
the system which is generally the
evaluative and comparative phase but
there are many steps that lead up to
that
in actual case work that you'll
that also need to be tested
in my experience as a bias researcher
there's often resistance from
practitioners and managers to
participate
and psychological contamination is much
harder to identify than physical
contamination
also the measured variable might not be
telling the whole story
and what i mean by this is that there
are challenges in understanding the true
effect of
contextual information so the result
that we get
may not uh account for the fact that
the same analyst can reach different
reach a different opinion on the same
piece of evidence at different
time points in the presence or absence
of contextual information
and this is often referred to as
intra-examiner variability
also different analysts can reach
different opinions on the same piece of
evidence
in the presence or absence of contextual
information we call it
inter-examiner variability
particularly in casework you can be
biased by something other than a
contextual information
for example time and resource pressure
or if you have a culture of
prosecutorial bias
and those are things that are very
difficult to actually assess in an
experimental setting
while trying to be unbiased you may
introduce a different type of bias
and we call this the biased lines force
you can of course be unbiased and reach
the wrong answer
or be biased and reach the right answer
now i have
right and wrong answer in quotation
marks because there's of course
a lot of discussion about what accuracy
really means
in the context of forensic decision
making
but this last point you can be biased
and reach the right answer
and sometimes maybe more likely to reach
the right answer is something that
gets debated in the academic and
forensic
circles and it is important to point out
that
bias does not equal error so they're not
the same thing
so it's very true that you can be biased
and still reach
um the right answer you just have gone
about it in the wrong way
so what if i reached the right answer uh
there was a paper that came out recently
where the author said
there is every possibility then that
cognitive biases
may actually improve accuracy in certain
decision scenarios
for instance stephen anderson bennett
found that tasks are relevant for
textual information
a dna match dna unclear or dna does not
match influenced or biased the decisions
of students
when analyzing fingerprint evidence in
both positive
and negative ways
so what they're saying is well if you
have context that leads to more correct
answers then
what's the problem unfortunately
conceptualizing bias in terms of
accuracy and this is a
key point and that's around the nature
of
scientific reasoning so if knowledge
and influence of tasks are relevant to
sexual information
if you have that it really undermines
the independent probative value
of the evidence
that is a fact finder may give the
evidence or opinion
more weight than it deserves
uh so let's say for example the
fingerprints
examiner knows the dna result and
they've incorporated that into
their findings and then in court a
fingerprint result
is presented as independent and a dna
result is presented as a disturbance
the jury or judge does not have no way
of knowing
um how independent that is and how much
how much weight to give each one because
it's being presented as independence
yes it's really not and and this is a
double counting
scenario in addition incorporation of
task irrelevant contextual information
makes assumptions about the correctness
of the extraneous information
and may lead you to explain away
non-corroboratory data
and this is uh what the finding was in
the brandon mayfield case where
um the examiners there were
inconsistencies
in brandon mayfield's fingerprint
versus the front of the crime scene but
they kind of explained those away
because they were already certain that
they should match
uh also using information from another
field goes beyond the area of expertise
so as an example you could ask what is
the true value of the fingerprint
evidence if it is influenced by dna
evidence
or how you know that you were not
influenced by the reference profile
if you did not have the opportunity to
view the crime scene profile
independent of it
so those are important distinctions to
make and it's also important to know
that information does not
equal bias so having the information
doesn't necessarily mean that you'll be
biased by it and also
even today i hear in working group
meetings people saying
a forensic analyst saying but i need
bias to do my job
and i want to make this distinction
because no you don't need
bias to do your job you may need
information but you don't need bias
so information uh is
the information that's used to inform
the decision which can be tasked
relevant or task irrelevant
whereas bias is the undue effect of that
information
so it's when the incidents the
information and
the task of relevant permission has
influenced the decision in
a logical way so there's a distinction
and i think it's important to recognize
that when
uh formulating methods to address it
so when is it appropriate to use
contextual information
the national commission of forensic
sciences put out a
piece in 2015 um
that defines what is task relevant
versus what is task
irrelevant and and
how they define it is it's relevant if
it's necessary for drawing conclusions
about the propositions and questions
from the physical evidence that has been
designated for examination
and through the correct application of
an accepted analytic message
by a competent analyst
it's nice to me here to tell you what is
past relevant and task irrelevant
but it's to make the point that there
are various tasks
during your examination and what may be
relevant in one
may not be relevant in another for
example
uh if you are at the crime scene
collecting that dna evidence then it may
be necessary to know
witness statements to determine where it
may be appropriate to
sample from however
that information is not going to be
relevant when it comes to
evaluating and or analyzing the epg
and when looking at the crime scene
profile
at that point it's not going to be
necessary to look at the reference
profile in case that has influence on
how
you then interpret the crime scene
profile
so it's about breaking down the tasks
and then identifying what's relevant for
that task
uh as well as identifying identifying
what what could be potentially biasing
and this is where contextual information
management comes in
uh the purpose of which is to
shield examiners from potentially
biasing information and that which is
not relevant to their tasks
while still allowing access to the task
relevant
information
now i like this quote from etl drawer
for forensic science to
successfully take on the issue of
contextual bias
it is important that one correctly
considers the risks
that measures are taken when needed and
that they are proportionate and
appropriate
now you thought earlier on i just
discussed the danger zones
now those are really the cases where
it's important to have conceptual
information management
it's not necessary to overhaul all
disciplines for all cases but it's about
identifying and understanding where the
risks are and then taking those
appropriate
actions when necessary
there are many different types of
conventional information management
procedures that have been discussed in
the literature
some of them are reasonably simple to do
for example at the crime scene
investigator wants to give you a whole
bunch of information
tell you all the theories of the case
and it could be as simple as saying
thanks but no thanks that is if i need
the information i will come and ask for
you
ask it from you however otherwise don't
say anything at
all of course being transparent is
really important
and and can
really help you to identify if later on
down the track a piece of
context that you have relied on is
identified as
being incorrect or invalid you can see
exactly
when you used it and how it affected
your decision and can go back
or theoretically go back and and change
um the course of action that you would
take or identify if
a change is necessary uh context manager
this one's talked about a lot where
somebody has all of the information
and they only pass on to the analysts
what is
necessary for their for their task at
that particular point
uh independent checking or review this
is another
uh one where which most
most practitioners i talk to have some
form of review
whereby it may be administrative or
technical
um somehow on every case some will do on
a proportion of cases
and the independent part of it is trying
to recognize that
the reviewer may be influenced by what
the first examiner has said
so is it possible you know if the
reviewer
is um
is looking at the case that they already
know how the number of contributors that
you've determined
um in a sample
well does that then influence how they
move forward with reviewing the case or
is it better for them not to know that
at all
and to try and come up with that on
their own is that a more
appropriate way of really reviewing and
assessing the initial examination
so there's quite a few different options
here and i'm not going to go through
them all because
it really depends on what discipline
you're in what the task is what
uh your agency kind of setup is like
but i'm more than happy for anyone to
contact me later on and i can
talk through various options uh specific
to your situation
and what we know is that there are
benefits
of contextual information management
beyond just minimizing bias
so you may be of the view that bias is
not so much of an issue for you or in
your agency but
there are benefits um to implementing
this
first and foremost maintains
transparency and integrity in the
decision making process
by mapping decision points you can
identify
potential areas for improved efficiency
and you know this there may be some
benefits that you don't even realize yet
a way that you can
speed things up or yeah it creates
processes that are more efficient
it can help you to thoughtfully question
the true value and scientific basis of
the interpretation
when you examine only the data so if
you're not able to reach an opinion
in the absence of additional contextual
information
then should you be reaching an opinion
at all
so as i said in the beginning it's those
cases of ambiguity that are the most
problematic so when you're really not
quite sure
there's not enough information there
that's when you're tempted
to reach out to get more information to
make you a little bit more certain
but it may be at that point that you
said well if i need more information
maybe the right answer is
that we cannot produce an opinion
there's not enough information there's
not enough data here
to support an opinion without context
therefore we cannot produce an opinion
at all
another benefit is that as we've
discussed fact finders are better able
to assign appropriate weight to evidence
when they know that each piece of
evidence is truly independent
and the expert is able to defend via
challenges in court
so if you're a practitioner listening to
this you may
may now have experienced
[Music]
defense attorney is bringing up the
p-cast report the nas reports
um studies on the potential for bias
if you have context management
procedures in place then you
are able to defend those and understand
really what those reports are saying and
why they're saying it
and of course safe adjusted outcomes and
that's
that's really what this is all about is
um
trying to make sure what we're doing
really is the safest way we can be doing
it
and thinking beyond bias to all
human factor issues now you know
initially
studies were just looking at bias but
now what we really understand
is that there's so many more parts of
the system
that humans make decisions within
and it may not just be are you biased
when looking at the specific evidence
but how reliable and valid are your
opinions in general
is the discipline in general
and what's the efficacy of training and
competency standards
so these are things that are being
looked at by various groups
for example the role of management
creating a positive aeroculture
impact of wording and statements process
mapping
and in osak the organization of
scientific area committees
um there is a designated committee this
human factors
committee that is embedded into every
discipline to try and understand some of
these issues
as well as minus but thinking much
further beyond that
uh and most along with nij
uh have expert working groups
in human factors for various disciplines
and their role really is to understand
the entire system and how
uh the human side of that can be
improved for yeah for safer justice
outcomes
so thank you for sticking it out if you
have
uh and these are my contact details
i'm more than happy if anyone would like
to reach out and ask any questions
uh if you have any particular
concerns within your own lab uh or if
you
you know are interested in in looking at
contextual information management then
please do reach out and happy to answer
any questions
and i think i'm just about on 30 minutes
i hope that you've managed to stick it
out and
that you're all home safe and well thank
you very much